in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
Brittany is here hey Brittany how are
you I am better than I deserve
how are you Dave just the same gone
welcome welcome where you from
Chattanooga Tennessee oh very cool very
cool and you're here to do your
debt-free scream yes sir I am I love it
how much have you paid off $100,000 Wow
how long did that take five years Wow
making what kind of money I started off
around $36,000 and I ended at $46,000 so
I averaged $40,000 but last month I just
got a raise
and so now I'm in the mid 50's yay way
to go
well congratulations so what kind of
debt $100,000 it was $80,000 was a
student loan and a $20,000 car Wow whoo
okay and so obviously you're single yes
and not for long though not for long not
long and you know hold up the ring let's
see it okay there it is
cool cool so what he wait on you to get
out of debt or what actually not well
when we first started dating it was a
couple months at slid at told him that I
needed to talk with him I said I need to
we need to sit down and we'd have a talk
and it was got to it was about 2 and 1/2
years ago so two and a half years into
my journey of paying off debt and I had
a binder and I slid it across the table
at him and I said this is my plan I have
$50,000 in debt this is what I'm doing
because he was he was living in Ann
Arbor when I was living in Chattanooga
so it was a lot it was a lot to commute
and everything and so I said you know
I'm not gonna be able to come up and
visit a whole lot just because I'm
focused on on paying off this debt and
everything and and he was like I totally
understand I totally get it
so he's been a great encouragement very
cool very cool show you have you set a
date yes sir May 21st
all right and we're cash flowing is it
of course you are
of course you are $100,000 in five years
what do you do for a living so I work at
Chattanooga State Community College
under the director of their reading and
writing Center oh and I also teach the
learning support reading and writing
classes in college success classes very
cool good for you
so what started you on this five years
ago is that when you graduated from
school no sir I graduated and thought I
owed it to myself to go $20,000 into
debt and get a call of course your
deserved it myself a gift when I
graduate yeah absolutely and then my mom
is very smart smarter than I am and she
gave me FPU as a Christmas gift I have
years ago
yes sir and not only that she said I'll
go with you to all of the classes oh
good I'll take you out to eat afterwards
Wow free food yeah now may I meet it now
I'm in for sure now is that your mom
with you yes sir okay I'm in her chair
continuing to cheer you on yes so she
started this whole process five years
ago she's got to be proud yeah yeah
absolutely we went to we did financial
peace so we did it one round and then to
make sure it's stuck we went two more
times so we've been through a few three
times you need to teach that now now
you're ready absolutely very well done
very cool very cool so what advice do
you have young single lady coming out of
school with all this debt it had to feel
overwhelming it did it was it was a huge
huge load it was um and CS Lewis had
four great CS Lewis has a great quote
and it's it's not the load it's how you
carry it and is it quote and someone
that has debt doesn't matter how much it
is if you've just graduated and you're
looking at this Mound
because I had a huge hole in a tiny
shovel but I had a lot of faith and I
had the Lord on my side and I just kept
going so if you're listening right now
no matter what debt you have you can do
it first step go to FB you do it do it
go to FB you if you are listening and
you don't know what to get someone as a
Christmas gift the holidays are coming
up
give them fvu whether it's your brother
your mother anything like that just give
them FP you go to FP you get an
accountability partner get on a budget
reach your goal and you can do it this
is very cool I did it it took me five
years you can do so
five years later when you look back when
you started climbing Mount Everest of
debt here it it had it was obviously
felt overwhelming so now when you look
back was the journey harder than you
thought it was going to be or easier
than you thought it was going to be
easier and I will tell you why because I
had wonderful family and I have
wonderful friends to help me my dad was
my accountability partner so every month
we sat down and looked at my budget and
I have two little brothers that are now
11 and 13 and when I started they
couldn't say snowball so they called it
a noble hahaha it's pretty good go with
that I would come I would come to see
them and say hey Berta cooter how's your
no-ball going ah it was it was great to
have that accountability my grandparents
my uncle Mike in Michigan just everybody
is encouraging me to do this and it was
without them I think it would have been
a lot harder but the support made it
much easier so Brittany's nickname is
Britt or critter yeah I love it I like
that that's a good one okay very cool
very cool so I also heard a rumor you
know some of our nieces and nephews I do
I do exactly know Erica and Scott and
Leslie
okay the morrow yeah absolutely they're
wonderful well congratulations Brittany
very proud of you very proud for you I
know your family is and this is a great
accomplishment I mean 100 grand is a lot
100 grand is a lot on 36 to 46 thousand
and five years is a long time
I mean you pull this off you can do
almost anything there's nothing you
can't pull off kiddo
very very well done all right Brittany
from Chattanooga $100,000 paid off baby
five years 36,000 to 46,000 income
during that time if she can do it you
can to count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one
yeah that's good we're also gonna let
her do training on how to do a debt-free
scream boom well done